MIDDLE.
HE CONNECTS WITH MARCHMENT,
GOING TO THE NET. FROM GIROUX.
HOLDEN ON IT, VERHAEGHE ON IT,[
RIGHT OF
AS CARTER VERHAEGHE GOES AFTER
IT IN THE CORNER.
TIED UP BY STÜTZLE, IT IN FRON
DOWN.
BATHERSON, NORRIS, ZUB,
THE GOAL, DRAWS THE PENALTY! TH
POST.
TKACHUK COMES UP WITH IT.
HE GETS IT
[ Cheers and Applause ]
WHO HAS NOT BEEN SHARP IN THIS
GAME AT ALL. ARE ON THE BOARD.
>> WHAT A SEE THE SURE WHERE
>> ARE THEY GOING TO LOOK AT I.
BUT YOU CAN'T THINKE NET, STOPP
BOBROVSKY GOT A PIE SLIDING BAC,
AND DID HE KEEP
WAY.
AND THEN REDIRECTS PASE GO.
OVERTIME W STÜTZLE WITH TKACHUK.
HERE'S TIM STÜTZLE,AT MOVE,
WAITS, OH WHAT A WILL DECIDE TH.
AND HE MAKES NO MISTAKE,E,